commissioned in a symphony and see bound
up with his mistress
we commissioning a symphony in C with
money is used to perform the peasants
was your mother you can use it as the
present December tenth symphony in C be
commissioning a symphony he can see
my love grow people don't know this was
about a dumb Hitler worse boo part kid I
was cake my favorite band of all time
passed and only a better badass past
dancer and I made it was badass man
edible come what happens to any of his
hundred shirts and he lost last year
anything I'm sorry no I remember that
man it was a bad ass piece of cake
had to go to the cake console right
right there in Hollywood and then it was
the cake it was a kid from their album
it wasn't I remember that day man fool
we have a mere cake comedian here man
what's up for you from the Laugh Factory
the first time I saw him one of the
laugh at you one of the videos everybody
run into each other alive oh yeah dude I
always loved watching be nice to your
posters to one out where our man it's
okay I'm here he's gonna be here yeah
love my band liars
you know Johnny rocky right here man
Johnny robust a lot of weight since I
sang last wasting away Lisa right here
and a weirdo steal ever over there
solution the floor whoa
I did a spanish job man
I wasn't I didn't already Tom Segura
myself his who's Trejo Fabricio it was
hosted by hold you by Cisco but he
didn't show up so his homeboys showed up
that's weird
it also means gay is gay so Jota is not
that's a letter JJ yeah so he owes dated
now Ramos Frank Ramos Francisco
Francisco Rob Frank he's not I called
Frank I called Frank I call friends go
Frank a lot of it was not a Frank and I
call for break us do Frankie Castillo
yeah so you saw Richard beer which would
be Richard Venus oh yeah yeah and it was
there bro a night he was there was the
death of you ta the you'd like do it
like he's looking for community to do
our Mexican run I could do 10 minutes he
shared tour over there
then he noted how skinny this fool was I
didn't even recognize him he can't put
empty dog I'm pretty sure the good man
Tom's first time doing specials it was
good no I'm saying how do you feel is he
back I have the jokes I just don't have
the translation down but see that's a
leg up on a lot of people though a lot
of people just have these you know
there's five minutes set of jokes and so
when I [ __ ] up doing stand-up comedy I
was deadpan mm-hmm my real deadpan like
like Steven right and then later of a
temper gene pompa but so I find myself
doing the same thing again it's bad oh
you're starting over yeah that's crazy
yeah it took a while to be like yeah
a lot of Barbies you know a lot of
attention waking up the audience ego you
know first you're more yourself now
though - you took finding your voice -
and being comfortable being yourself but
I think that's the thing you're getting
yes because right now in Spanish you're
not comfortable to be like you know just
show up to the second set of the hour
yeah I mean the second half yeah I saw
your seat are bare together so yeah do
it in español español
is there a border here something and
there's a lot of people that are manhood
just guilty Tom Segura justice he'll do
anything bad so fast but pizza but I was
in the bathroom and there were these two
girls talking about how small the room
was I could overhear them but they were
just total white girls talking like and
I knew they didn't speak Spanish and
they were seeing Tom and they were like
yeah no wonder it sold out so fast and
she's like I'm so excited to see him I
haven't seen him ever and I they were
talking about Tom Segura but they had no
idea I don't think so these girls did
not see but she said it wasn't very if
it wasn't very clear the first time it
went up and I think she got a lot of
calls they should have dropped the
screen and put subtitles small I know
they'll still oh yeah it was very small
like some of the name like you just
twist it to the right to see what was on
one marquee on the low marquee even even
their big marquee
you can't see that unless you're like
right on the other across the street cuz
they can't angle it enough I think there
are some city ordinance or something
they were saying - yeah
Podcast why does it burns drug sports
have live chat um just go ask them you
know next time you're on on their show I
think she's happy I think that she's I
think she's happy that that's that's a
it's a concern right now but she's just
saying why doesn't anybody listening who
not on a live chat conspiracy Kate okay
bass enough I think as punch-drunk gets
in fights too many fights with their
listeners and the listeners fight each
other and then that's what the thread
becomes fixed episodes only you should
watch it oh I see more so native posted
ID these two comedies are gonna make
guys start watching you know female
comedians wait so what's up there girl
what is that on a new thing for women is
gonna be you know the first one was Kira
Kira so television yes you would be
Fisher and right before when Ali's came
out and Ally its blew up baby the money
yeah you gotta be pregnant you can see a
chick with like 17 kids here
muffled I seem to be doing comedy
alright I'll come out with a stroller
Robin - the baby right let's take live
of empire actually come up with a black
eye how'd you fall bus your eye dog so I
don't catch myself my hand so my face
yeah we didn't get you coordination
classes we had a black eye she showed up
to San Angelo 1st October she's talking
about him
you got the good Rick you got a good
right hook forensic files on Google Maps
you ever ran into a door dude I did that
one time at night I was getting up and
it was dark in my room and I was walking
like this and then the door came right
in between my hands bro a [ __ ] nose
I'm going to do the little run around
[Laughter]
man jingo though I had the worst
whatever man
when I forget who say its host anus of
networks with drop the [ __ ] two-tone
batter and his told ya he didn't drop a
two-ton battery what happened no no what
happened no like those big-ass car
batteries no it was actually uh it was a
it was a one-ton battery it's a forklift
battery at the it was a distribution
center for the postal office we were
doing a job it was on a pallet I knocked
it over
yeah and that we wanted to put it back
up and it was four or four guys trying
to shrink pull it and I do it got
dropped and it cut my finger Oh skin for
my wrist to cover it up Oh dude that's
like live right there Jesus Christ I got
a warm people before you do the [ __ ]
hand it's beyond pain my life gave me
Demerol
yeah I could still feel the nurse
cleaning oh my god yeah pretty much yeah
you know right Swinehart yeah I don't
know what happened to these fingers got
snapped Oh what okay so he was he was
like at the lake well he was at the lake
and then he was like on a jetski late
that's where it all starts bro lake with
the jetski oh yes I'm sure like that and
he had he they were towing his jet ski
right because he like broke down and a
boat came and got it but with some like
thin ass like rope they're towing it and
he tried to like whole wrap the rope
around his finger and then the boat took
off and boom and snap these two like I
don't know but yeah that was a clear no
dude it's rope dude it just like pulled
the skin and everything and then he lost
like the nails I guess of these two
fingers here but it like imagine the
pain of that bro photo it's brute
my dad so to hit my dad sawed his his
right pinky off when I was a kid he was
a construction worker but he he was
distracted and he just sawed it right
off and he got it reattached and my dad
was so lazy he never worked it out he
never worked it out and so he just said
just take it back off again no you can't
really tell like did it have color and
stuff in it or was it like completely
dead or was it I was able to move oh it
was able to move once they reattached it
but he had this little exerciser he was
supposed to do like all throughout the
day for I don't know three four weeks
and he didn't do it
yeah he just he lost the nerve feeling
eventually in the way yeah but he was a
big guy so you can really tell and I
hate to shake people's hands but then he
go hah and freak people out he'd be like
oh and then realize he a mess anyway
trucker that broke it off slamming the
gate down on a rail no not a car
accident I was making I was doing stupid
demonstration of my gymnastics told you
twirling oh it's in third grade you not
doing no no I broke mine well yeah they
were parallel bars I was acting like
they were they were uneven bars which is
what you know those gymnasts do the
spins on and everything but I'd never
take a gymnastics class yet I had took
that many years later but there are
uneven bars and they spin and twirl and
jump to each one you know so I did it
but I did it on parallel bars which all
you do is smash your face on that when
you go forward there's no space nothing
and I I said I woke up with a bloody
nose everywhere it was good
what the hell sighs thank you and the
teacher came over so what do you think
cuz I just went okay watch my friends
are watching me and I don't know what
didn't see like Mary Lou Retton the
weekend before or something I mean yeah
that's what it was inspired by that
stuff I just thought if I have those
things at school but they weren't the
same they weren't uneven bars they were
parallel hussein's homey that same dude
it's mother's brother needs to work with
he had a friend that was lived in born
in Mexico needs to watch Superman so
when they came to the United States he's
all were in the United States now now
I'm really Superman so this what goes up
the front window dog eat [ __ ] all his
teeth scrapes up the front face now for
that they call them an maletto part of
the windows is grass two-story window
ran Lou did you guys ever do that [ __ ]
with an umbrella orange yeah again
George Perez calls me hometown yeah grew
up in Orange County city of Orange yeah
I do and that's it man
and yeah we moved there from Iran the
apartments in yeah dude when I was five
years old but yeah it was a trip because
I was the littlest kid in our
neighborhood our little apartment
complexes so they'd always like test me
out with [ __ ] one time we we were was
like a spider-man thing or some [ __ ] or
we were I don't know we had Batman
shoelaces and they wrapped the [ __ ]
around me and they we try to rappel down
so they put it around my waist a toe and
yeah and I was going down the [ __ ]
did its shoelaces tied together and like
not even two seconds into them like
putting me to the thing whip up and
[ __ ]
slap and I just landed on my ass dude
like two stories not to story but like
the one story if you want to get stuck
in a wormhole though look at YouTube
with that [ __ ] like every day woops the
kitchen open up a bunch of jalapenos and
put sticking fingers in them so when you
rest and you fights dirty that's dirty
we used to do dirty says they want
Tabasco like if someone fell asleep like
you know we're having like staying at
friends houses or something and somebody
fell asleep we put Tabasco and wake up
[ __ ] rub it into their mouth and they
wake up like they're pissed off no we
really wanted to mess them make somebody
like get hot with a mouse have you ever
seen a little chili those begins oh yeah
hotter than like anyone touch your iron
you dare Vinnie for 10 bucks to eat one
with the thorpe ax dude my mom's feeding
the milk grab the stick starts beating
on me for doing it people chatting hey
so when you pull out the Bible your
little kid people feel sorry for you are
you doing a wheelie malindo know that
one time we're teaching a philip how to
do a ollie does treasure show them the
ollie back this way messes up his elbow
goddamn dog
we're just sitting there going dude
we're almost afraid laughing he's gonna
get off man no that was right there
where uh where these two live off the
Chevy Chase remember we were a little
thing that was little yeah
that's only time I said everything you
eat [ __ ] on a bike though mine we're now
recently is too we're so Johnny Rocco
with their metal jacket bucket you told
me you got abs now bro oh yeah it's nice
[Laughter]
no I started coming in LA I moved to LA
and I started at the haha dude yeah
that's where I spent a lot of time in
the beginning
cuz you know I couldn't get time
anywhere you know when you start in LA
it's like [ __ ] impossible to get up
unless you find the mics and sure we
were talking about chuckle monkey that
was the website when I started yeah yeah
Ken Pringle dawg
yeah whatever happened that ville
Midwest but I remember like chuckle
monkey ty Rivero don't I be talkin
welcome he was the guy that I remember I
met him I thought he was like this dude
that was like the thing I really like
older dude yeah
you're the wife right yeah we're glasses
like glasses like a [ __ ] you from the
60s right yeah a little chubbier you
look like the penguin damn fool I never
met the do you know yeah but I saw him I
remember there I do that's the guy from
chuckle monkey we're all up in my course
and we're like oh my god dude no Mike I
love your website
yeah but that was the site where you
gonna find all the mics now it's what
Bureau I don't know there's a bad Slavia
whistle I don't know there's random ones
but I'll chuckle I've been out of the
loop for a minute
these open mics now you should love the
matter what they put you up for this -
lady you got me there friends yeah oh
yeah it's net it was never like you get
up on a random drawing you know it's
like yeah dude random I mean you're
randomly using it selected but it's like
it's just like anything I always tell
comics you know you got a hangout man
you just got it cuz that's how you you
know you become friends and then and
then that's how you get on the shows
then your friends who are also new at
comedy eventually started rooms and then
you get other bookings you have to start
a room cuz if you don't have currency in
the game when you're starting
you're just a taker I'm gonna have
something to give or do something you
know have something to offer ped a
little ass or something well you've
given a lot of people stage time just
for driving new places yeah and like we
like to sing about you dog don't be a
fool inside dog who you take you take
Johnny on the road who do you take with
you Johnny was legal where is it East
Coast sometimes like a local person
voltron full job photon school Keith
Manning and Texas area was going home yo
yeah Chuck Martin
you come around and he was so funny man
and they wasn't like wow who did get
over a spot huh
no they [ __ ] they were like I need come
and kill every week and he was like and
everyone thought he was super funny and
he'd sit at the store and he was just
waiting to go up and we do Sunday Monday
every every Sunday Monday there and then
yeah they seen give him love man
he killed it the antics went one time
boy always kills the place party he
better album - I
so Alto yeah he was good he was like
one-liner e-type yeah jokes and Larry
bubbles Brown Murr I heard the name a
lot I was funny yeah it's funny man
sometimes you go to the city and there
it was twice oh that guy yeah he's up in
Modesto area maybe when you're gonna
have a long bad
the portable podcast over there or
something I don't know Jesus Christ had
a biker gang you know Birdman's one step
away from being Jesus Christ dude he's
right man like just this much away from
being that guy older you are the Hat
yeah I was going there for a while dude
I saw bouncer get murdered over there no
no that was another times there no no
this was like he went to his car came
back huh the dude knows like it was a
group of guys and then I guess I saw the
story later though it was about oh they
came in with a fake ID no I heard the
commotion bro from the green room on
with the San Jose from the San Jose and
probably windows open yeah you can even
look down you can see the club right
there and then I hear all this commotion
or should I look down and there I throw
them [ __ ] those those stanchion
things you know those like the ropes the
for the line you're throwing them at
each other [ __ ] I'm like what the
[ __ ] there's a getaway car take off
and I'm like what the [ __ ] is going on
down there and I find out they just
stabbed the do to the net
the bouncer came up over a fake ID bro
no just killed the dude and he was like
you know like really softball coach or
some [ __ ] league coach or something and
like everybody loved them and they
carried the body out right there man I
was [ __ ] gnarly but that city is like
no joke
cuz someone got shiny killed in front of
the Improv we're now Oh about that Chris
story what was the Pirtle whole thing
when he watched the whole thing he saw
commotion just like you yeah and Eddie
Griffin was on stage and don't you know
make sure that any Griffins crowd they
come out there when the cops are out
there and the body was right there they
were hoping that anyway people go along
oh that's like a first time I always
hear about him you're like three hours
but the rest settled everything out what
everything came up but they seemed
nothing you know it was cool yeah yeah
that place is great yes quarter huh dude
I mean the whole place is you know at
night when people get [ __ ] up they're
like you don't want to like even walk
into the hotel but I'm like no joke
that's a young danger he works at the
San Jose Crime Lab what happened bro I
don't know what happened right now boy
what happened there was something it was
him so he starting at the flappers no I
know I saw dude I just I I worked there
for free to get up on the open mikes
because it was five bucks I didn't pay
five bucks every time so I was like [ __ ]
it dude let me just work here all this
for five bucks to get on the open yeah
no no I wasn't gonna do that I'm gonna
be here every night I can't pay five
bucks to [ __ ] go onstage cuz the five
bucks would get like a drink or some
[ __ ] but I was like I'm gonna be
here - no but I just told him I was like
dude I'll make phone call I got nothing
to do Jack come on we're blood
I'll make the pool table yeah dude
everyone has a history with them you
know like I love that Club buy something
worth five bucks
yeah drink a beer like a water but if
it's empty
you know like staying open
I don't know what's your history know
that Oh looking clean I don't even know
this bro yeah you were drinking nothing
else yet so I'm arguing with another
comedian and comedian with Bragi
initiated cutting people off you know
like mid-sentence like you then wants to
be the loudest you know go talk to taco
taco talk then I stay listen matter you
were [ __ ] if you made $450,000 last year
I don't know how much money you make on
cartoons I know
oh and I heard this story when I was
there
well I was I'm funnier than you and your
wife she'll want to suck my dick
I will PT who's cheesecake bro
[ __ ] Stevens big house he threw a
drink at you first and then you lunged
at him you went across me I thought
you're gonna choke him I thought how
wings die yet a Red Bull and then had a
Red Bull I don't know that that grab you
Jack grab me from the legs he had his he
was hugging your legs on the ground
damn I saw Willie Barcena and Adam
hunter [ __ ] you're trying to get the
guy behind the bar and the day I was
hiding behind a bartender female
bartender hiding behind a female
bartender brother one he was harassed
you know you kaamika yeah yeah he was
crazy yeah he was hiding behind her and
then Felipe went and kicked his car oh
good I heard about this you say I
remember cuz you never were there when I
was I was crazier bro is that I was so
angry that I was looking for any any
link to my old gang my car like [ __ ]
Hey who do I go you go hey Dawg you
still together
I call him a homeboy bro will happen to
you I probably will chair down hey bro
you know pastor nobody back if you need
something set up some Air Force Ones
goddamn I love Jeremiah Wow but then
after that bad like that was just years
of that [ __ ] talking [ __ ] though
do you know I was like oh yeah well your
I wasn't actually there
but I've been in other circumstances
already kind of like you know tries to
belittle people and shouldn't be a dick
but that was just [ __ ] [ __ ] brewing
for you you know that's crazy yeah it
was like a different thing and then when
I got there was totally different time
but he was still around the guy who come
on you see no the fight that went down
buddy I broke it up oh I heard about a
drunken aam well how does Thornton
butthurt so [ __ ] some Matt kebab bro
hey I'll be on the record right now
Willie Barcena came in and you know he
had you know how Willie is although bro
but all my specials on tape anybody want
to watch yeah so he had already like
been whatever and then he came at Club
and I met him director this is Willie
Barcena you know they were telling me I
was a new comic and [ __ ] and some I'd be
around there all the time just working
you know so I can get up get it get
stage time and Matt Taylor was on stage
and Adam Hunter was hosting so Willie's
in there and he's like talking shade
about like everyone's stealing his jokes
or something he's like man I gotta steal
my joke this guy steal my joke and then
he's like this and Matt Taylor was on
stage and he's like dude this joke right
here is something about you know the
Mexican border or some [ __ ] like you
know the [ __ ] joke everyone whatever
some [ __ ] something and then he's
like dude this [ __ ] guy's doing my
joke right now and he's like that
[ __ ] probably probably probably
taught him how to do this and he's
pointing at him hunter and I'm like and
I just heard on my adam was outside like
getting his bag or something and adam
was in between bringing comics up and he
walks back in he's got his backpack
interesting theory there William
dude he comes in with his backpack and
then he walks past Willie and really
like elbows him dude like that and then
you add him just like looks at him and
keeps walking and then he just socked
him dude what really just socks I'm in
the magma cheap-shot kind of a sucker
punch dude just like because Adam was
already shooting him probably huh yeah
it wasn't even looking at any split his
lip bro and then Adam jumped into like a
you know
you see the UFC fighting or that sort of
stuff to say it through an interpreter
but anyway so anyways that should happen
and then he's Sargon I'm out all right I
was outside I saw the whole like the
whole [ __ ] like I had just walked
outside and I'm looking because I saw
exactly what you know when that thing
happened on my go that's nothing you
know I walk in and I saw that and then
all of a sudden all of a sudden Adam has
him in a tight clean look out dude he
has him in a Thai clinch
I don't hassle ya bro in there yeah
they're like kind of what kind of like
well you know a Thai clinch like around
the neck so they wrestling they were
like wrestling and Jack's again like
throwing around and they're like Terry
you know Terry oh my god like yelling
everyone's yelling and then I liked when
I opened the door and I grabbed Adam off
of him because he was like right by the
door and I grabbed at him and I pulled
him outside and then that's when got in
willy shirt was all ripped up and he's
yelling like quotes from [ __ ] blood
out no [ __ ] Spartan movie what is it
309 in hell clean up [ __ ] right
little Zeus
so Sal do you think that Willie knew
that Adam I don't know I think it was
like he was about the whole thing but
Willie's really fights or boxes or some
[ __ ] right I don't know man yeah it was
just stupid it was dumb but Adam did
have him in a Thai clinch and you know
they were trying to do whatever but when
I when I pull him off Adams lip was like
just gushing blood cuz it split like
right here clip no huh yeah and I mean
you can still see and then Jay Davis was
there and took him to the hospital and
then me I was like a new comic I go hey
Adams out nobody went to the hospital
got stitched up
I remember Jack junior went over there
and saw him that's people with the shots
for it yeah a shot yeah I got his mouth
all stitched up inside a bit but yeah I
was [ __ ] up it was just dumb I don't
think it was just being drunk or sober
huh I'm sure he was drunk to you cuz you
could tell he was just getting heated
over Oh as the night went on and he was
like talking through the side of his
mouth and [ __ ] whatever dude wasn't you
seen a fighter coming so they broke it
up
what's that I saw you [ __ ] hear the
story about the [ __ ] right you want to
tell it was of Iran the [ __ ] was down
tonight
well they like what they know jack was
like grabbing his arse I think I'm hurt
I think whatever maestro watch him
audience no I saw a girl getting her
hair bird-like at the land oh yes her
hair kind of fired and it threw water on
her but I saw a fan threw a drink and a
girl on the way out oh and they were
like no chair that girl with a shut up
nice inna yeah but that's it I saw a
fight between a biker club with a
bouncer at the hop in liquid oh [ __ ]
no throwing for kids tools bro where do
we hide I went outside that's what we
went outside dude I was gonna be in
there caught with the bar so to the face
yeah we didn't know how that fire
started do but it was it felt like dunk
and those dudes were bikers but they
didn't come in dressed as biker but
they're just like regular people but
when I get when the call came in a star
shape they came they threw on their
jackets no no jackets but the next week
every was mostly with more security
guards but there was no more fire
Uribe their point it seems like that was
something that they kind of set up rocky
Roe their man even let your finger cut
off now I got a fight yes all fight
before comics not comics I was like the
best fighter I saw wasn't like
elementary school bullies so what was
the vibe room I got to the final eight
people talking about it oh they were
everyone's talking about it when I heard
stories like I heard a lot of I heard
all these other stories I'm like dude I
was [ __ ] there like I don't it blew
up out of proportion I mean was a two
second fight he was old maybe 15 20
seconds max and what I saw Adam hunter
at that sound - pretty sure yeah and I
never haven't seen him since what I
heard what happened and he said well
that were they happened he thought that
all the Mexicans could mean they were
gonna turn on him or because he said
that it was actually the opposite it was
the opposite bro cause I've been working
West Covina ever since fight where at
the clubs oh I've seen tons of fights
but I know comedy clubs I don't know man
I don't think so
just like guys about to fight over jokes
or something really yeah
wait carvings yep what was a joke
airplanes pool come on yeah I don't know
it's most of [ __ ] stupid right at the
end of the day you sitting by cadence
bro who he said it to you know what tell
Mom we're on the phone no I had a dream
of Willie and that's what I've had a
dream about you broke that I was there I
was happy now staying with some chick
and then Willie calls me up little bro
that's the way I thought I see people
doing your she a young Latino comics
being like you oh we just heard about
somebody in San Jose doing it yeah
there's guys there's guys I've seen it
[ __ ] is don't Felipe pretty much I
see it I mean I've seen it a few I had
somebody call me up and ask about a
comic but I mean that should we do self
out you know you
like that [ __ ] weeds itself out even
like jokes thief's and all that like
those do go far you can everyone we all
know each other like en man comedian
named Rudy Ortiz in San Jose
doing my stress my job you know like re
no they never stop you from doing that
they don't do that joke that's an old
joke and so then it's like a ortiz find
a new job bro hardly anybody know that
comedian will hit them up stop doing
that job it's embarrassing bro still
from comedian nobody knows like how sad
like always stressed like how he made
money off that joke and you have it on
the record right what you're doing that
i get money for that joke on [ __ ]
itunes yeah yeah what do that please
appease those SoundExchange
start off with like I mean bogey right
gonna start off seeking it but if you
don't write your own [ __ ] from the
beginning you're not gonna write thing
you do that's we're like continued and I
know like also like if you started off
comedy to be an actor you're gonna have
the [ __ ] same stand for the whole
your your whole life well they're new
monologues yeah they're do monologues a
lot of the time they're just like okay
this is the set and I can do this and I
can pretend to be funny in this like a
comedic actor I make a little money on
the side and everything but yeah if
they're really wanting to be an actor
will be tough to wear that [ __ ] funny
monologue though well there's still
funny people they're funny
it's just they don't have more they
don't well they don't work out right get
more over you know they just like this
15 minutes this 20 minutes they'll get
me by and I'm good with it
you know so I will be the first TV show
first to break the first comedy I mean
my first TV thing was like MTV show is
called jerks with cameras it was a prank
show mmm-hmm was that [ __ ] yeah remember
yeah you and Carter Grande Kotter
is one-nothing Craig Carter from [ __ ]
now he's from OC no knowing from Molina
he live in Catalina in San Diego yeah
just less firms but he started a comedy
no see yes that's where we met and then
we met on the show we came we have a log
Avalon Twitter yeah yeah yeah and Jeff
Keith was on it it'll just entire was on
it tone Bell hosted it told Bell it was
fun dude and so funny randomly I was
attending out like two days ago
and this guy's like you're that guy from
the show mo MADtv he's like nah dude
jerk the camera for all the people who
don't listen you know we're gonna give
what really happens these shows you did
all the writing and performing for the
show right it'll be right for you um no
we did all it was it was kind of more
you just did it the way you wanted to do
and then they did have some setups and
stuff but I remember we would have some
problem with that because we're like
dude we're funny guys like lettuce
[ __ ] just riff and do our own thing
and then they had like kind of teaser
[ __ ] that they wrote that they're
acknowledged just try it this way and
then you can do it your way
so we would purposely do with no energy
like hey guys today I went to the park
and I got you know and they ended up
using that so you look like an ass on TV
yeah I remember I was working with ADA
Rodriguez shelter in a rodriguez climber
year and saw her at the [ __ ] um
premiere of us last night her now we're
gonna comedy or the car or the pilot for
like a wedding roast uh-huh we hang out
with a wedding couple and then we roast
them at the wedding reception and really
roast so they wrote a bunch of jokes for
me to say about the roast and man
somebody's job were really really whack
yeah I don't want to say they're whack
and I stand up there but I laughed at so
I'm okay I'll use that one then I
probably looked the wrong and I said I
said how many times can I say it during
my show I didn't write these [ __ ]
wack ass unfunny [ __ ] jokes
I said just like that ya know mother
[ __ ] worked or six of them alright new
jokes which I didn't use like a new hire
you yeah it's because I want your [ __ ]
they just wanna prove they're doing
their job yeah yeah yeah
there were hard to write they're gonna
keep writing
when I give you the [ __ ] now bunny
they're gonna keep [ __ ] writing like
alright I could write dirty jokes are
not funny right away but I couldn't
write one you know that's gonna be fine
yeah it's true yeah it's funny with
those with those type of shows like like
if you're we run your whole set your
whole life and they give you right okay
now you gotta write 50 Jose about this
you're gonna be struggle your whole life
you want that job to be funny yeah but
if you're like a writer they write with
your pop and they don't care cuz it's
like they throw it away and it's not for
them 15 I've been on I've been on shows
were like dude I just got a turn out
these jokes and then like give them to
the comedians and see whatever and if
you know there's no credit involve I
mean the credit is like you're just a
writer on the show but it's not like
you're doing it for yourself I just went
through the show and they would tell me
they will call me in the forenoon to
tell me if I want you to write Joseph
bar and I'm going to court give me 25
jokes all right but now I never really
checked it with her funny
I thought they were funny you know but
but I wasn't at first I thought with it
but I'm never riding in their voice yeah
but there wasn't change it to their boys
I don't wanna stay in a loud but man
what's that
I got I got well dude a lot that's the
problem with a lot of the show yeah
they're easy as [ __ ] easier it was
barely it was friendly jokes
yeah it was like God what does whatever
the Fred Arbus to see what he does that
but is well a comedian I love Neil to
let you know it's me I was our problem
no no no I did Adam Devine's thing how
are you yeah dude that was dope cuz we
had a week I saw the promos for that
before he was shot
and I really thought I thought he was
really Hawaiian no my wife looked up I
say what he wasn't well that part it was
so dude that one my soul are chicks bro
all happy oh it was so fun he loves
chicks yeah
we - alright I'm Adam little out weed
there yeah I don't know I don't know
about that see but we had a good time
here there for a week we got to be there
for a week cause no we were in North
Shore at the Turtle Bay Resort Oh and
IRAs or cuz we had like [ __ ] fell over
the weekend so we got a whole weekend oh
just like chillin on the house house the
shoes dog rented scooters went around
the whole [ __ ] Island it was awesome
it was a blast bro
Wow the Turtle Bay one yeah I was
thankful for Billy all shudder - acid
acid cry what's up bro thank you for
listening who donated five bucks or the
podcast man people hit me up all the
time so I'm gonna hit me up the other
day like Felipe I need your help
my grandma died we need money that was
their pager look what post I think this
a scam do a lot of those are scams fool
are there other going after light I
guess they just go to whoever I guess
huh but I see a lot of people will reach
out like randomly but then you yeah I do
a little recon I'll go and research and
you see it's maybe this is a scam
they've tagged several other people yeah
and it's always like they go after like
you know some comic this comic in Iowa I
just don't know why we just hung out you
put a couple of blunts but then this
will hit me up like another blue but
just threw me off but but it just threw
me off crazy like a male being our limit
let's gonna bang your house they held up
bro dude I have a family that you got me
yeah dude my son lives in a garage the
back front house whatever right I
thought you know care hell no yeah we
actually shoot at that board yeah like a
one time here but it got worse bro do
you talk to Kyra glass yeah maybe you
want to buy be a hearing aid oh wow this
guy's got requests from tempies another
broad question bro yeah some because
some people do I try to be nice to
comedians on the road you know I'm sure
you do too like when you know that
they're a real comedian
yeah but some guys hey you don't be the
guy's guy know how I was when I started
do what I can hear you yeah he's great
guy
no look you try to be cool with the guys
that are you know that are serious but
then you got a weed them out you never
know [ __ ] these guys like you said
they'll hit you I came in like have no
idea I want to crash at your place and
you said come you know like what the
[ __ ] are you talking about you show to
our layers on your porch your front
steps yeah I had to come and do that al
you know al from economy story he came
from magical no no cuz how I met him in
Houston and you know yeah yeah he can't
and I was like dude you gotta move to LA
if you really want any Papa no but he
men I know a fool yeah yeah man that
fool with me bro I'm going crazy boy did
ya not anywhere that like the corduroy
dragons I have have personality know
yeah yeah exactly so I met him in
Houston I was like dude if you want to
get serious come to LA and one day he
just showed up dude he's like I'm here
and I was like oh you know I was given
the pep talk to the comedian they're
like dude if you want to be serious go
to New York go to LA and he showed up
and full ended up crashing with me for
like three four days dude because I told
him I was like hey dude if you come so
[ __ ] it dude we're doing the laptop and
I was there was a Gabri glacier my femur
and off I went me and no the Houston
comedians approached us to talk to up at
the regular the bar all week right the
author they were too good I guess but
that walked up to us so are we gonna
guess by Alex cool he will get one guest
but he was younger than all those people
right and when we told the older
hello yeah he went over there everybody
get the [ __ ] out of my bar get the [ __ ]
out of here
don't [ __ ] think you are you're hard
mighty take them out damn that would
inspire - oh but don't laughs - laughs
stop last time okay so he did his guest
Pablo went up and did a guest spot
whatever this will be an open mic
outside right and then this this these
fans come outside I start fighting
brought outside like a domestic fight
and this this karmic [ __ ] start to
break up the fight and that do puzzle
share her bra back the chick yeah and
she's just the open microphone she
should have do an open mic and she's a
[ __ ] local PD Oh double whammy
you ruined two lines I hear and then
that fool like he goes we're gonna stop
this guy I said her dog find out where
we so they didn't chase him but I guess
he like regretted it and you just sat
down and knees bro like and waited for
the cops
oh [ __ ] after he punched her yeah damn
fool before okay that club was crazy
laughs stop that one a bit uh bohemian
yeah I'll behind me he's been in there
for a minute that's how you say his last
name right boy I didn't know lb lb yeah
he's a cool kid like him
he doesn't like that's like producing
[ __ ] and that went when I met him
wrapped in of 1990 something damn full
2000 with other one when did you start
I started 1995-96 oh damn okay alfred
knopf 94 yeah your vet and when I
started you already are you were like
last comic standing [ __ ] winner and
bro you're the [ __ ] you had just gotten
less comics that with my big break that
was 16 years
sure yes I won't be able destur December
not in December it's probably gonna be
more like
late summer fall Modesto was the would
say you do it theater there Chuck Chuck
you're Chuck your rule when the [ __ ]
rated lots of the Patriots and [ __ ]
time rate of the rookie and either the
tuck-and-roll
rule he grows the ball then he fumbled
it and they're like each other he lay he
lied to the referee and said hey des I
don't know man but they came up with a
new but an old rule football that he
chucked it so when you chucked it it's
like you down the ball right but he
really fumble that [ __ ] out of the ball
he grabbed it and down there's the
beginning of the interaction of Tom
Brady's before the flake ruined
everything so that my first time in
Modesto Modesto by the way a lot of
people hate Tom Brady really yeah they
do but that's although it's [ __ ]
Raider Nation brother everybody saying
but - no California is Raider Nation
everybody there where's radar radar
jerseys that are that are [ __ ] red
that's where Manny's from right mom yeah
you have that bro
yeah Manny dude he took me on some first
gigs dude yeah we went out [ __ ] where
he took me too I remember Howard Hughes
in Arizona he's diving those crying
right um on a bar rescue
yeah yes yeah Howard so I met him at the
haha used to DJ at the ha ha and then he
moved to Arizona and started a club and
then yeah that [ __ ] was crazy for cuz
Mandy didn't think he was gonna get paid
we were like [ __ ] we went out there you
know ordained some shitty hotel and he
had some gig in like Glendale Arizona
bro it was like some [ __ ] Club and we
did the show and Maggie's not where the
[ __ ] my money dude like we're like he
was pissed dude
Howard was just all [ __ ] up and he was
like partying and Denis ignore just hang
out man I get it for you
and man he was like about to lose his
[ __ ] on this guy that's pretty crazy you
know coming dates I do I'm tomorrow I'm
actually gonna be I just live right yeah
oh yeah tomorrow I'll be in uh where am
i I'm in funny bone in Hartford
Connecticut oh yeah all week and then I
got a bunch of [ __ ] on my website Amir
comedy calm so a lot of dates coming up
la for games
addameer comedy everything yeah what's
up full of be in Dallas Texas March 29th
to 31st at the Arlington improv April
4th to the 6th the comedy zone in
Charlotte North Carolina April 9 if the
show of our time puto espanol viva los
cheetahs at Riverside performing art
center
it's a Riverside life Arts Building on
the corner of lemon and University dummy
food
I know there's gonna be drinks but I
don't know about food okay good and you
can only get tickets are you ready to
roll $10 yeah you announced it those
we're both Spanish right yeah the show
is in Spanish so combo comedy club best
club out there in Northwest April 18
through 20 years no one's gonna be in
French Microsoft Theatre it'll be an
Armenian Los Angeles wait that's not
Microsoft theater that's your doing
Microsoft here later this year and I
hope yeah my bad but this is for Kevin
and people April foolishness no April
foolishness k-rock april foolishness
April 26
Microsoft theater I'll be there doing
that's a charity show but it's gonna be
fun you slept up restored and Casino
Albuquerque New Mexico April 27 get all
my dates at philippi the world comes
last order i harvard art bar
Thursday night smart me with Harvard
Yard bar Thursday nights man Martin
Rizzo how's that going good locals are
showing up
what's that downtown LA not Koreatown
okay look out then go get a Monte's
burger till 2:00 a.m. Korean BBQ dog how
you been to the Hartford funnybone
before I have the first time I have been
there man how does it all babies the
biggest ball the whole world know yes
use that more the more you know Mall of
America that's the biggest one I get mad
when the rest I'm into mall you never
did that one the [ __ ] is like a
water park yeah inside you've got weird
yeah Canadian yeah nice and pink that's
right the heart for 40 boys fine ma'am
well that flew away man I had a whole
green bro that's nothing vegan days are
irregular here being a days so I went to
I started so I walked from my hotel room
like in the parking lot myself ballpark
you got nobody was there I saw target I
was open to it like 24 hours he cop some
popcorn or I bought a bunch of poo
Gardein peanut butter and jelly bread
milk everything man do you do that on
the road you don't you like get the [ __ ]
and put in your hotel room that's the
way to go right oh yeah man so when I
hang out with a stab at the end of the
night and I'm hungry they [ __ ] to eat
yeah I know and I do you can't eat that
garbage food anymore man I can't do it I
know math you know Twitter for a long
time before oh I ate without chicken
tenders taking Tanner's popcorn shrimp
damned so yeah I don't know no no I'm
gonna be taping something soon though I
got to get some of this [ __ ] out I just
waited too long did you have a couple of
our videos on the laughs pastor there
were a lot of views yeah they did and
what I [ __ ] up as I didn't put it on
my own I just had you know their stuff
and and I just wait I just was too
precious to my [ __ ] and I just I'm gonna
put it all out of your money I did get a
couple checks and then all of a sudden
it stopped but I know those views keep
going up I mean like there's a couple
million you know it's like [ __ ] we're
going cuz I heard what is do you know
how much it is per million it's like I
don't know if any grandeurs yeah I don't
know but I got a check couple times for
like 15 re yeah I would check with them
because we got a check for something a
while ago and then we asked them not to
put any new any stuff over that way
forward yeah and so they agreed not to
but we got some checks off that original
stuff and they people still watch it
dude the views we have our Rachel Whoopi
will be common
woofs in and she had a million views
over time
yeah a lot of comics having I'm telling
you I have like those [ __ ] videos
have like two three million views of
them and I don't know that that's like a
lot of money right mad monitors yeah
when you perform at the we perform at
the Laugh Factory
your regular laugh at your it
accomplished I'm regular I'm not a
regular at The Comedy Store yet no but
I've been there for years man you know I
had some [ __ ] with Tommy and then you
know oh you did yeah I don't think he
liked me he just never liked me yeah I
know but then they'd [ __ ] carry it over
I think I do my spot you know I do my
Davone spot and I do a bunch of other
pretty shows but that get improv my
place improv I mean the Comedy Store
I still do spots Laugh Factory I do
spots ice house although my wife and I
about that guy David wasn't even I don't
think it's David it's the older guy who
does this shows on Sundays I got cards
and it's like a credit card
yeah man I always see that I never met
it's like well a factory but I take how
many strong yeah you don't [ __ ] with any
problem you don't really do anything
locally occasionally yeah I do like some
chili so and others don't so I gather
and give George so George or sometimes
though all things comedy will put on a
show a Comedy Store or something oh it
has some straight home and I was Spanish
or San Diego I got two of them coming
out so are you gonna start doing more
Spanish [ __ ] yeah we're gonna to turn to
our special Hispanics are you gonna go
to Mexico do some stuff or how is the
scene there's it's I'm gonna do a
special but I'm a part of Neverland
tour that Spanish I just want to do it
yeah
cool yeah just to do it because I want
the splendor that the my Spanish I don't
know if I'll translate in Europe but I'm
nothing translate in America and that's
what I want you know and I'm gonna be
like that the main dude is Spanish in
America what I want to do that's cool
but I wanted to be like people to
understand it like oh [ __ ] I could
relate to him because I'm a I'm not yeah
exactly Iranian American like I like to
appeal to the people that are like me
yeah and I see it more and more at the
shows you know they come out and then
like whenever a kid comes up and goes
dude you know [ __ ] that's cool we
have one you know like like you because
we only have like five comedians bro
there your honor yeah that's like and
then more and more kids are starting now
so it's naughty lingerie on tour with
him for years you did yeah that's my guy
we do our room - yeah [ __ ] cool
dude bro like for yeah he taught me a
lot bro like how to be you know busted
yeah and when I we're sad also his show
ran more late no longer well yeah oh you
were at Wilbur - yeah and then he was
there yet we made up Dan Smith right
yeah Dan Smith all he always has Dan
open there you know that yeah I know Dan
I don't know if you were there though no
no I probably wasn't there I stopped
touring with him maybe all that car will
you bet no I was like if the show was
taking a little longer some well yeah
LeMans he always wants to do a little
mas writing for TV oh this is just naked
yeah this is a jewel dude [ __ ]
[ __ ] got to sponsor me as many
of these that by Bobbili gotta be honest
yeah yeah I had a pack a smoking
cigarettes I did bro I smoked all and
you know when you driving style bro over
and over not not Armenian more you know
Iranian American I would smoke only at
night when I drink I always thought that
I wouldn't only because a couple of
spots where I mean
to hang out at Burbank and Hollywood
like I felt like I would live with a
[ __ ] purpose I stopped smoking which
I thought was just for them I think it
was these we do I liked it because they
have their own [ __ ] there sometimes I'll
sit there here's a conversation play
cards bad suits oh man it made you feel
like you weren't at a corporate yeah
smoking hard though man plain table
whatever the [ __ ] plane
yeah backgammon and [ __ ] cards and
[ __ ] yeah look at squishy oh they're
stretchy
she's cute bro did you have dogs I do I
got a wiener dog man i love that
[ __ ] yeah I had him 13 years bro
folks cost me a lot of money because
yeah like back problems neck problems
yeah yeah but he's a g-man I love that
if I didn't have him brought I don't
know what I do you know you're lonely
bro [ __ ] you bombed all night you come
home you get some love from the dog you
know squishes dope though just a little
bigger it's like a warm blanket you know
like yeah that little so we did the MTV
show then what else we did what else I
did a couple movies man I got like like
this movie called the pyramid early on
it was like a horror movie and the first
thing I did was Argo actually with Ben
Affleck I got a little smart part in
that really I played the first passport
check point where they're like about to
leave yeah and I checked their passports
and it was pretty cool dude they got it
closed up in that [ __ ] movie for like
you know 30 40 seconds only but uh it
was supposed to be a little longer scene
but you know how they do it they cut the
[ __ ] out I was just happy to be a part
of it got a SAG Award [ __ ]
because we want ensemble cast
so that was I was like don't be hanging
with Tom Cruise join Scientology and
everything
know so I did yeah oh yeah are go
thinking I booked this this movie that
shot in Morocco this horror movie called
the pyramid back in the day like [ __ ]
six years ago now and that was really
cool and I thought I was going to do a
lot more acting but I don't know man
Persian back to TV dude just did
stand-up in a MADtv
was a lot last like you know a big TV
thing yeah he was on with ancho Johnson
right that season no no I didn't back
they did a rib Angela came back you can
write with a Latina girl yeah all
Michele Ortiz yeah yeah yeah okay I was
like what yeah that was fun but it was
like oh you know one year see one season
I'm sorry and uh cool it was a lot of
fun learned a lot but I think it wasn't
the right you know it was like it was
like ten years behind the [ __ ] you
know I mean the types of change and I
didn't change really with the times
they're trying to be a little bit too
you know safe and [ __ ] it was on prime
prime time I'm not late night so
whatever they couldn't get a good we
like doing jokes and [ __ ] in the the
table read the pencils would be smoking
their standards and practices people
like yeah and then so like and they
don't have a late-night programming for
on the CW so I was like dude we were
[ __ ] handcuffed man so we couldn't do
[ __ ] and it was just like it was
frustrating cuz you'd be like riffing
funny stuff Adam Ray was on to be like
we just got a talk-show thing and uh
yeah buy time at air do you just it was
hard to watch for me but whatever man
let's talk about some more depressing
proofread that suicide letter I was
working on my suicide what happened
brother Matt see me after MADtv bro just
focus on stand up early really we
started touring we go to MADtv right
pretty much now was like that was even
though was the season was just something
to for them to sell you know how the
clubs are they just wanted one so MADtv
they want to see the [ __ ] thing and
then they could they go bad TV and then
they expect Bobby Lee to come out it's
me
no but it was good for my touring
absolutely like people come out you've
been through like lark love we've been
to right I always see you on the fly
that's true I always see like you go to
the bathroom taking a piss and sleep a
big ass basically coming soon you know
the tempo a problem yeah it's like thing
but yeah and there's like five got you
know there's five or six guys you see
always in the rotation I feel like we're
chasing each other like Harley Williams
harland's on their lot steve-o randomly
only people yes what he brings his own
prepared meals
oh these begin to yes we refrigerator
over there in the green room yeah
anaconda have you done Raleigh North
Carolina yeah no Jews there oh yeah that
was it does cool I mean this isn't a
weird place but it's I think they're
making out those clubs so big they
cancelled our show because of weather
right that was in Rochester oh really
we're just Raleigh right with that
club's huge yeah those new ones are
falling apart
I had to get the staffs really cool yeah
I knew everything new in probably nice I
don't know Coconut Grove yeah we're not
that like weird you just walk out in
your on see I love that
Oh Melissa was cool too yeah the same
people run it I love those people so
that what are they been doing they sent
him to Tampa or some [ __ ] I think I
don't know I'm not Tampa I'm sorry they
sent him to hope that other West Palm
Beach
yeah the casino I remember seeing them
there after so the new club is good is
it it's not in it's not in South Beach a
little rail okay
oh nice tell you guys man I was like I
drank too many Cuban coffee this time oh
you see wired drank three of them less
than an hour down the phone nauseous
yeah pour through it uh this is that's a
lot of weight I love a lot of weight
being over there because they need
tortillas just rising beans and bananas
yeah it's like peanut butter jelly
sandwiches no one least another butter
is that your thing Nutter butters that
be nut butter fudge you make every once
in a while I think once every six months
it's like that like I make it every day
that big bro like a little plate and I
and I started out with just eating two
cubes right with milk with her bra I get
up to the morning have a coffee
oh that [ __ ] down
well I thought myself bro like doing
stuff that I seen on TV bro like like
him and James like that [ __ ] fun
without being around I try to cut a
piece what I could a big-ass piece but
in a shame to later should still look
round you cut around start molding him
violent [ __ ] alright a whole cake
cutting around it yeah you're telling me
bro about how fat you were bro you said
you eat other people's left oh yeah
like from your table or other people my
table we got new bit of the cleaner
but I'll be vien in my food and people
I'm down give me your pancakes to bite
you you're bloody together what do you
do now to prevent you hold yourself back
from doing it yeah I don't eat that
I tell me but I don't eat that stuff is
that easier to like restrict your diet
so yeah once yourself to restrict
yourself
yeah havior if I get a little bit I want
it all they were like we're back through
there with no leftovers yeah what do you
like smoking weed [ __ ] me up though
when I come home from the comedy club
dude I smoke a little and then I just go
eat everything I have in the cupboards
bro you know
me too 9 moles of cereal yeah just one
more one more
there you go when I was a vegan and we
had like a zero there were not being in
like frosted mini-wheats
that [ __ ] wouldn't last a day in my
house I'll [ __ ] get a break it apart
so I have more to do turn it into
porridge the guys change bro are you so
fast it's just because they're late
little thread sometime right choking oh
yeah you [ __ ] with puffins bro you got
to go to Trader Joe's has the cereal no
not peanut butter they have the
multigrain [ __ ] gluten
you gotta go there while he was eating
beef jerky in the green room so won't
you Scarfo pasta like your ham wishes
yeah yeah well I was no I was like this
in high school but I was like wrestling
I was running I was doing a lot of like
workouts I'm gonna broke your heart
wrestling sandwich I went to college I
read more you got ate and ate and ate
but like I'd eat sandwiches really
Rodrigo
I need sandwiches try to make like big
ass bread sandwiches right Mayo who
slices two slices Mayo but like thick
Mayo thick mustard everybody with two
meats have both I would do ham and I did
the ham and the chicken breath and then
I get the yellow and the white cheese
and I'll put them together off that was
good man
I used to like eat coffee cakes if I
still hate they're so puffy so just math
- it broke if I could eat it better and
faster oh my gosh that guy was crazy how
little that guy isn't how much you can
eat hey there's a guys that eat more now
right on the couch he was like the
Michael Jordan of my time bro be like
for the first time back in the day
I grew up eating just Mexican food man
if it's new I [ __ ] out of here man like
the first time I had like Persian food
like oh sorry
shamsher Egyptian territory yo you got
to go to Rafi's even Rafi's over here we
got to go Rafi's were Rafi's is right
here in Burbank really dude it's the
[ __ ] Glendale let's glad that chicken
was here people by the [ __ ] fire
station yeah that's you gotta go to
Rafi's bro we got to go there we got to
go there what's the big city after dish
for Persian food we need a lot of meats
with rice right like the kebabs and [ __ ]
with rice and then there's stews that
are [ __ ] bomb the stews you can get
like a vegan stew I believe but I mean a
lot of stuff has like chunks of meat in
it stew meat lamb okay we made that
kebab but it was like it's like yeah
ground up beef with like onions and then
they put some [ __ ] in spice and stuff
yeah chicken coup be nice to [ __ ] up
that plate right there our chicken was
here right there back to the fire
station on Grand Avenue and Glendale
I was a little Armenian spot yeah where
the coffee little coffees that meals
more and Paul everybody looked like in
the next door was a guy that was a
position okay he stay Armenian song I
guess but he liked all the albums were
his albums and he sold most of the
concerts for the people who I mean like
they loved putting pictures of
themselves up like Middle Eastern people
yeah I went to [ __ ] Beirut bro the
guy has like he's got a picture with a
microphone I go is that the singer they
like no he's a mechanic
ya know for really because they all like
gonna be like you know like the real
estate guys you know they have their but
for every business they have their
picture on the [ __ ] front that's the
Maryland he's on that area yeah it was
also sold out three nights in a row and
now there was a lot of like approaching
people or Latinos or half that you don't
have 30 people and ever I say that we're
kind of similar people you know you guys
like walking around showing off your
chest hairs you know mask you we like to
walk around open show in our stomach for
TV it's gonna be about the lethal yeah
actually he has a cousin yeah Martin
emergeny was half Mexican
he's our Maryland [ __ ] DC when we go
with her yeah yeah
that was I always having to in DC improv
yeah Martin used to open for max I don't
know like yeah like tour together in
March is cool what's awful but you got
Ben Stiller Instagram rookie John so
partners right I know I got a haircut in
Miami will definitely [ __ ] you up bro
you said it's been years dude it's been
more than a dick like you like three
like you should be good here but Becca
always is there always a point where
you're like looking in the mirror you go
if they stop now would be great yeah
[Music]
[Laughter]
that was the wrong update there are old
he this guy was old school barber bro he
hated the Beatles right that's a staple
of all school party yeah stop cutting
their hair
oh that's right I see what you're saying
okay I get that I get the thing now
there you go oh that was last year
around February just before my birthday
before we were going up to the Bay Area
for that show
damn this one left an impression yeah it
was horrible she cut bangs for me but
this was the day that she was talking
about her assistant who had just gotten
like locked up in an insane asylum and
she's telling me this story and she's
getting all emotional when they do this
and I'm watching it happened and at one
here's yes anyway she cut my hair and
then she also colored it that day and it
was orange it was orange I had bangs was
horrible horrible period of time and it
lasted and I couldn't change the color
for the four weeks because it would have
broken my hair off it would have run it
so I because I met with some woman and
she said I can't touch it for like four
weeks we got to let it settle
you let her cut with emotion when I was
junkie like I it was horrible it was a
horrible experience
and I hated myself when we were up in
Oakland that last minute where's your
supper bag what sir food take you a mere
K for being orgasm a podcast
it'll be on either tomorrow morning or
Friday morning but uh the YouTube video
will be on right now so now my mom don't
watch kids have wonderful weekend
everybody
yeah my